Let's take a look at
the alien adventure app.
You're going to see this
app in different forms, but
the core concept for the app will be the
same every time that you work with it.
You start with their hero robot who
needs some help exploring this strange
new planet.
Above the robot,
we see some dialogue, and
if we tap the screen then we can
progress through the conversation.
So tap the screen, and
our robot starts moving along.
And we've reached our
first alien encounter.
I'm going to be quiet for now, and
I'm going to let you read the dialog.
Well, that wasn't so good.
Our robot didn't give
the alien anything.
But that's where you come in.
Each time a robot encounters an alien,
a question is going to be asked.
It'll be your job to correct
the code responsible for
making the robot's decision.
I'm going to go ahead and
make a quick fix and
see what it might look like if
a robot answers more intelligently.
Okay, let's give this another go.
I'll tap and
I'll let you read the dialog.
Nice, the robot made it through.
Now you probably noticed in this demo,
each alien always asks
the same question.
They were looking for the most valuable
object in the robot's inventory.
That won't always be the case.
As you work on this app,
we'll keep introducing new more complex
questions, but I know you can handle it.
The robot's adventure depends on it.